en el pequeño corregimiento de tutendo
virgelina salas lleva 20 años atendiendo
a pacientes con malaria en este año van
153 pacientes con malaria Esta
microscopista visita analiza y hace el
seguimiento de todas las personas que
llegan a su consulta con síntomas
compatibles
Entonces ya si les ha dolido la cabeza
se han tenido un escalofrío si le ha
dolido el estómago si han tenido un
dolor de espalda si les ha dado fiebre
pasan a tomarse la muestra este niño de
9 años debe hacerse la prueba en unas
horas sabrá si es positivo en
malariado tú tu nendo es una de las
localidades más afectadas de Colombia
las condiciones medioambientales así
como la minería ilegal son factores de
riesgo en el departamento del chocó en
la costa pacífica los casos han subido
cerca de un 60% en los últimos 30 años
mientras la media nacional se mantiene a
la baja sin embargo el paludismo no solo
se da en contexto Rurales en la capital
departamental esta problemática también
persiste
alguien está pendiente para el
diagnóstico La microscopista Tomasa
Santos recibe cada día a un goteo
constante de personas en el laboratorio
en este hospital local la universidad de
Antioquia desarrolla un programa de
investigación sobre paludismo en busca
de una posible vacuna esta mañana llegó
John Arley un minero de 19 años que ya
ha pasado la enfermedad en 8 ocasiones
no da mucha protección uno atrae por la
necesidad porque no hay más Poco después
de hacerse la prueba llegan los
resultados Este joven nuevamente tiene
malaria Y esa especie que tú tienes
ellos tienden a dejarlos en unos ojitos
en el hígado aún te tomes todo el
medicamento O sea que tiene que ser más
juicioso que lo que tú no te imaginas
él promete que se tomará el tratamiento
pero pronto volverá a la mina
en el estudio de la malaria en el chocó
cooperan todos los estamentos locales de
salud en el laboratorio departamental
comprueban la calidad del testeo no con
el control de calidad nosotros lo que
hacemos Es que garantizamos que esa
bacterióloga sea idónea para dar un buen
resultado al paciente aquí trabajan
junto al equipo de entomología encargado
de analizar las particularidades del
insecto mirar el comportamiento del
mosquito resulta taxonomía cómo se
comporta cuáles son sus sitios donde se
crían Cuáles son los sitios más
vulnerables que él pueda tener una labor
conjunta para atajar la malaria en la
región más afectada de Colombia un país
donde se siguen presentando más de
70.000 casos anuales